J'ai l'impression qu'en tant que scientifiques
Nous avons beaucoup à apporter, en particulier dans
un
scénario de changement climatique je pense
nous sommes la voix de ce que la nature ne fait pas
Peut dire
[Musique]
il y a un il y a un changement dans la colonne
l'eau et nous ne savons pas comment les organismes
et plus particulièrement les micro-organismes
ils y répondront à ces fins pour
ces changements principalement dans
salinité
[Musique]
2022 2022 doit tout changer
cela et il y a déjà une décision concrète dans
aller vers des politiques profondes
de changement de la façon dont nous faisons les choses comme
humains
[Musique]